we are very excited about our next guest
she actually gives great hugs I've been
hooked by Tina he's an award-winning
writer in magazine he's also got a
dagger of a pen which will yes that's
true too but we spent the past three
decades chronicling the British Monarchy
Brown's latest best-selling book is
called The Palace papers inside the
house of Windsor the truth and the
turmoil this is an in-depth look at the
past 25 years of the British royal
family something she knows a lot about
the new paperback edition includes the
monarchy's most recent history including
the death of Queen Elizabeth Tina Brown
is also we're proud to say a CBS News
oil contributor good morning to you Tina
we had morning
so much has happened since oh God since
since the hardback but we spoke to you
after Harry's interview was 60 minutes
and at the time you hadn't read spare
you have since read it and you you what
do you have to say about that well what
surprised you most what do you have to
say it is a real raw Cry of pain this
book
um extremely moving I thought uh much
more uh important book I thought
actually than than people perhaps might
have expected because he really takes on
so many uh you know issues about
monarchy and and yeah it's pretty
riveting
um it is of course though his very
personal prism because it's his Memoir
and should be but of course the palace
papers will give you everything that
shaped that moment essentially and the
rest of the family who who are this been
in his book are only seen through the
prism of his sort of his rage really
about being marginalized as as a spare
which is the hardest thing to be in that
family but you know you see history
repeating itself and how Princess
Margaret was also a spare and how she
struggled you know in in that system and
she kept it in too Tina she didn't talk
about it she didn't so I'm thinking
what's wrong when according to Harry he
has tried tried very he's tried a lot to
reach out to the family to work this out
privately to talk about the pain that
has been caused what's wrong with
sharing that part of your life and your
story because I know in the UK it's not
going over well or at the palace it's
not going over well well it's it's a
mixed issue because obviously the
rockets that he's fired have landed on
them right so they can't really they
can't speak within their system that
their you know formality of approach
means that they cannot respond so
they've had to sit there and sort of
take the attacks in a sense without uh
defending themselves and I think that
where I do find him uh uh where I do
find him somewhat unfair is about his
brother William because it's almost like
he doesn't allow uh for the pain that
William has been through you know I mean
in in Palace papers I talk about you
know how Diana really came to depend on
William he was the he was the older
child and they were very very close and
she used to call him my Wise Old mom
because he was a very sort of serious uh
sober child who was you know lifted up
his mother a great deal and it was very
painful for him when she went through
all of these very public affairs and she
you know went on the Martin Bashir and
did the book with Morton and so on
because he was older he actually
suffered you know you can't say more
because Harry was suffering tremendously
but he suffered a lot as as the eldest
boy and of course he's had no choice in
his life either I mean he's actually
just got to get on with it and be king
and nobody asked him if he wanted to be
frankly Tina Brown first of all nice to
meet you thank you David uh you wrote in
a recent article I suspect the next two
months to use a psychological term are
the sussex's extinction burst what did
you mean
I actually meant you know there's a
psychological term which means that you
know the extinction burst is when you
just let it all happen you just bring it
all out and it leaves you kind of
perched if you like that's clearly what
he'd been doing this has been an
Extinction burst of Harry emotionally
the question is
will it be at the end you know because
the family will feel okay so you've had
an Extinction bus but what about us I
mean we're now bruised and battered you
know so it's almost when Harry goes on
TV and he says you know I now want to
have a Reconciliation it's like well
yeah but we're like we feel like Prince
Charles is wounded we're still very
wounded about it and and and and and
kind of don't know where this has come
from you've also got King Charles and I
love to say transitional Monarch it
doesn't seem like what every prince
wants to be when they grow up uh what do
you mean yeah but he is a transitional
Monarch and there's no getting away from
it he's you know in his 70s uh you know
he he hasn't got long to make his Mark
and he waited and he waited I mean you
know when the queen in the last year of
her life was constantly canceling
engagements you had that moment when
Charles in her stead opened Parliament
and the crown was sitting on this Velvet
pillow in front of him and I felt that
the thought bubble should have been when
when when am I going to put this goddamn
you know crown on my head you know so he
finally gets it and of course as soon as
he gets it his son starts to let rip so
he is in some ways you know Chelsea was
used to his great sort of motto was oh
just my luck he used to say yeah well
it's sort of just his luck just becomes
king and spare lands on his head yeah
and there are so many many people that
wish William was King they didn't just
skipped over so this book does not land
on your head you're such a good writer I
mean you're so witty and uh the
paperback you can stuff in a sunbag kids
you know the weather's going to be
warming Now's the Time I do encourage
thank you thank you Tina Brown Palace
papers is out in paperback now wherever
you like to buy your books